Now that you're equipped with some basic skills necessary to acquire
and clean up data, we'll use these tools in order to
begin working on our class project, analyzing the dynamics and workings
of the New York City subway system. First, you'll use your
knowledge of how to acquire data via an API, to obtain
weather underground data on New York City, for a month in
2011, and write it to a file. We'll then use our
SQL skills to run some basic queries on the data and
get a sense from what our day looks
like. Once you're comfortable with the weather data, you'll
grab a bunch of data related to the
MTA subway itself from the MTA website. In addition
to gaining some basic familiarity with the MTA
data, you'll do some processing and cleaning of that
data. Such that it'll be very easy to do
analysis on the data in the very near future.